just because we're really hungry they
eat a lot they've got eight tentacles
and two big feeding tentacles they'll
eat anything that's right besides
they're not too picky
the pigs are strong you're underwater
you not in your element so you have a
reason to be pretty weary to hear
biologist David Hann described the
Humboldt squid conjures images of
man-eating monsters and deep-sea
leviathans of old but the Humboldt known
to spanish-speaking fishermen as Diablo
Rojo the Red Devil poses less of a
threat to hapless sailors than to
Fisheries along the western coast of the
United States and Canada coincident with
measurable average changes in water
temperature over the last 34 years
they've been moving further north and
more consistently now every summer they
move further north since 2003 Washington
and even southeast Alaska they show up
now quite regularly on a dreary day in
October hand gives the public a very
close-up and squishy lesson in Humboldt
physiology using their parent like beak
that's also made of chitin they um kind
of just go through it almost at
corn-on-the-cob there's I'm terrified a
little faster so there's a fair bit of
hype every time these guys show up you
know whether they're offshore and eating
all our fish or washing up on the beach
by the thousands people kind of get
psyched but we also want to believe in
monsters too and you know as great as
that is these are real creatures that
might have real impacts on the ecosystem
and so I think it's kind of nice for
people to have somebody who can say like
look look here's here's what's really
going on this is how much we know and
here's what the real creature looks like
you know touch it you can poke it here's
the beat you know you know just kind of
clear up a little bit of mystery but
hopefully retain some of the interest
while not completely understood a
Humboldt extended range appears to be a
function of its biology squid in general
are
kind of a fast turn over weedy species
they grow fast that reproduce quickly
and they die young
yeah the James Dean invertebrates
these guys are served in exceptional
cases this and that they grow really
really large in the space of less than
two years they can get up to six seven
feet long 100 pounds or more at their
maximum and they do this by eating
voraciously and having incredibly high
rates of assimilation that they what
they're eating they can turn straight
into body mass really really efficiently
much more efficiently than other
creatures females can have over 300
million eggs so they can just reproduce
really really quickly and respond then
perhaps to things like climate change
ecosystem change other prey and
predators much more rapidly than a sort
of slower growing slower metabolism
longer live species in addition the
Humboldt can survive in low oxygen
environments despite a very active
lifestyle what's unique about these guys
is that they spend a lot of time in the
oxygen minimum layer which is a sort of
center of the water column far away from
the photosynthetic zone where
decomposition has led to a real minimum
oxygen water water conditions and so you
think of a squid as being the least
adapted creatures to be hanging all the
time there but there's some sense that
they might have adaptations that are
it's kind of like hibernation that can
suppress her metabolism slow down and
yet they still seem capable being really
active so there's there's quite the
mystery there of how they managed to do
this Hamm says that how far and how much
of an incursion the humble makes into
North American fisheries remains a big
question mark right now especially all
for North America for the United States
and Canada we're still the stage of just
really kind of studying them and then we
don't have any fishery for jumbo squid
yet except for you know kind of
recreationally so it might be the amount
of time kids basically get like a
supplemental large
Berger who knows where we'll end up with
this
you